How long can you hold your breath?
Science says without training, it's gonna be about a minute.
Let's give it a shot.
Some people such as free divers can hold their breath for a few minutes with training.
But scientists have no idea why this is.
Or why most of us gasp for air long before we turn blue in the face or pass out.
In theory, we should be fine holding our breath for much longer.
After all, our lungs can hold about four minutes' worth of air.
But at some point, our body forces us to inhale.
Researchers call this the "breakpoint".
How does our body force this breakpoint?
Maybe, a sensor in our arteries tells our brain that our blood is getting low on oxygen.
Or perhaps, our lungs are warning us they're low on air and forcing us to inhale.
Science has rejected both of these theories.
We now think it's actually our diaphragm signaling our body to take a breath.
Test this out yourself.
Next time you hold your breath and you're about to burst,...
...try relaxing your diaphragm with a partial exhale.
This little trick should help delay your personal breakpoint.
Okay, 52 seconds; that's obviously not gonna break any records.